vereint vor einem knappen Jahr auf dem
berühmtesten politischen selfie Herr
knapp
der großen Ampel Liebe damals hat man
gedacht mit Robert Habeck und Christian
Lindner sind das jetzt etwa Freunde
geworden hat man sich damals gefragt
jetzt ein Jahr später kann man ganz klar
sagen nein tja Habeck und Lindner die
beiden im großen Zoff um die Kosten der
Energiekrise und um den Weiterbetrieb
der deutschen Kernkraftwerke da sind sie
in der Scholz Regierung mittlerweile
ziemlich beste Feinde
[Musik]
so familiär fing alles an mit diesem
selfie startete die Ampel mittendrin die
beiden Alphatiere Robert Habeck und
Christian Lindner knapp ein Jahr ist
dieses berühmte selfie jetzt alt das
Familienfoto der Koalitionäre Geschichte
inzwischen müsste es musikalisch eher
heißen
so richtig scheiße
Christian Lindner und Robert Habeck
politisch und menschlich kriselt es
inzwischen offenbar gewaltig so
stichelte Christian Lindner gegen
harbecks gasumlage eine Maßnahme der
Solidarität kann nicht dazu dienen dass
einzelne Unternehmen ihre Rendite
pflegen und gewinne darauf machen und
das muss man sich genau ansehen um was
es da geht ich kenne die Fakten da nicht
das kennt der Habeck viel besser
von wegen family sieht anders aus
Zickereien vor allem beim Thema Atom
Lindner und die FDP wollen wieder mehr
Atomen für Robert Habeck unter komplexes
Denken ein Aufbau einer Argumentation
die sagt die Atomkraftwerke sind unsere
Lösung wird der Komplexität und auch der
Aufgabe die wir wirklich lösen müssen
nicht gerecht aber ich würde diesen Kurs
weitermachen dass ich mich entlang von
Fakten hier durchhalte und nicht und
nicht im zuruff Folge Lindner kontert
auf derselben Veranstaltung es ist doch
völlig klar dass dem Robert Habeck es
schwer fällt über die Frage Kernenergie
zu sprechen ist doch völlig klar es geht
da nicht darum jetzt man sich
wechselseitig das Leben schwer macht und
die die politische Auseinandersetzung
damit pflegt sondern es geht jetzt hier
um eine Krisensituation
Harbeck und Lindner die Gegensätze sind
nicht nur politisch groß der eine fährt
Fahrrad der andere Autorennen der eine
golft der andere Joggen der eine Typ Öko
der andere Manager und jetzt auch noch
diese Gerüchte bzw Gerüche die Frage die
im Raum steht kann Christian Lindner
Habeck nicht riechen der Finanzminister
ist angeblich irritiert dass der
Wirtschaftsminister beisitzungen die
Schuhe auszieht tratscht die Berliner
Polizei Zähne wie bitte fest steht aus
ziemlich besten Freunden wurden offenbar
ziemlich beste Feinde
wie viel Krach kommt da noch auf uns zu
aber ist schon eine Frage jetzt ne
ralfschule unser Parlamentschef hier im
Studio wer ist der mächtiger in der
Region von den beiden Habeck oder
Lindner und vor allen Dingen reitet uns
dieser Zopf noch tiefer rein in dieser
tiefen Energiekrise sie tragen das ja
sehr kultiviert aus man muss sagen dass
der Finanzminister natürlich als
derjenige der die etato Hoheit hat schon
einen Tick mächtiger ist dafür ist
Robert Habeck Vizekanzler ein Titel für
den man sich nicht viel kaufen kann
bringt ihm jetzt nichts er kann einmal
im Jahr wenn der Kanzler im Urlaub ist
eine Kabinettssitzung leiten das war es
dann aber auch das Problem an diesem
Zoff ist allerdings dass da wirklich
zwei völlig unterschiedliche politische
Lage aufeinander stoßen die FDP möchte
einfach versuchen so viel wie möglich
wirtschaftsliberal bürgerlich die Grünen
auszubremsen und habe hat einfach das
Problem dass er einerseits das muss man
mal so hart sagen von Wirtschaft keine
Ahnung hat aber ist auch relativ Lachs
angehen lässt also es beschweren sich
immer wieder Kabinettsmitglieder dass er
schlecht vorbereitet kommt dann muss man
sich eben auch klar machen die Grünen
haben eine Doppelspitze an der Fraktion
Spitze an der Parteispitze haben sie
auch eine Doppelspitze und dann sind sie
auch die Minister der Grünen nicht grün
untereinander also habe ich
beispielsweise mit Steffi Lemke über
habitatrichtlinien und ähnliches mit
anderen Worten habe ich es nicht
abschlussfähig das heißt man versucht zu
verhandeln und dann muss habeg erst noch
mal die Abstimmungsrunde mit all seinen
Parteifreunden machen das dauert das
nervt und das ist bei Lindner und bei
Scholz anders und habe gut auch mal laut
weil er sich nicht beherrscht und nach
22 Uhr berichten Teilnehmer von
vertraulichen runden wird er auch etwas
ungeneißt weil er dann schlafen will und
das ist ihm dann alles zu doof also es
gibt da auch so atmosphärische
Geschichten grundsätzlich ist es aber
ein politischer Streit der auch sehr
zivilisiert ausgetragen wird also man
brüllt sich da jetzt nicht an oder oder
zockt immer in der Öffentlichkeit aber
es steht da ist kracht doch ordentlich
inhaltlich die FDP möchte AKWs langer
laufen lassen die das will habe
dezidiert nicht
der Kollege Finanzminister möchte ganz
sp und die Schuldenbremse einhalten habe
gesagt ja wenn es nicht geht dann muss
man mehr Geld raushauen und diese
politischen Lager prallen da eben in den
beiden aufeinander
wird er das Ruder jetzt in die Hand
nehmen die Menschen interessiert vor
allem wer wird dafür sorgen dass wir
durch den Winter kommen ohne dass wir
frieren müssen und zwar insofern dass
wir unsere Rechnungen bezahlen können
wer wird also da so ein bisschen mehr
das Ruder in die Hand nehmen also Habeck
ist quaamt dafür zuständig
und er muss ohne unter anderem diese
eben angesprochene Energie diese
gasumlage die muss er überarbeiten dass
er da auch zugesichert wahrscheinlich
wird man sie komplett kassieren aber
schon recht lange weil das Problem ist
dass man da völlig stimmbehaft zu Werke
gegangen ist anstatt sich einfach an
diesen pleiteunternehmen zu beteiligen
und damit Stimmrechte zu bekommen und
die anderen Gesellschaft damit ins Boot
zu nehmen hat man hier eine Umlage
gewählt die dazu führt dass auch
Unternehmen Milliarden bekommen vom
normalen Gas Kunden die es gar nicht
nötig haben und man gibt den Menschen
einerseits einmalige Heizkostenzuschüsse
und andererseits schlägt man selbst eine
Umlage oben drauf das ist nicht logisch
das wird so auch nicht funktionieren und
deshalb muss Harbig erstmal nachbessern
das ist nicht schön fürs Image aber im
Wirtschaftsministerium ist auch der
wirtschaftliche Sachverstand immer
dünner geworden in den letzten Jahren
weil man auch die Grundsatzabteilung vor
einigen Jahren ans Finanzministerium
verloren hat da gab es noch ein paar
Experten jetzt hatte man sich eigentlich
darauf vorbereitet das Weltklima zu
retten und nun kommt die Energiekrise
das ist unfair die Weltgeschichte aber
so da muss er durch
[Musik]